- But here's one thing
that I love that you did.
I think you did it at
the beginning of The Talk
this season is you talked
openly about facelifts.
- Yeah
- Because it almost makes it less taboo
and less of a topic if you do.
That's what I love about Dolly Parton.
She owns every bit of it.
She's like "Yeah."
- Sure everything.
That's it.
Yeah yeah that's true.
- I love that you do that.
Because while some people might not
be comfortable with that,
some people are comfortable with that.
That's why they love to do it.
And I love that you talk about it openly
because a lot of people don't.
And they're like "I
haven't had anything done."
- This is just the new cream.
(audience laughs)
- It's my new cream. (laughs)
- Yes try this cream.
It lifts everything overnight.
- Lies and deception!
- I know it's like oh please!
(audience laughs)
- Is it hard?
Because I'm scared of
stuff, I'm terrified.
I can get tattoos, I have like 15.
But the thought of something.
I'm scared of it.
So you're never scared?
You just go in and you're like "Yeah."
- I am, I am.
Yeah sure because you could
wake up and look like Cyclops.
(audience laughs)
You never know.
And I had this thing where
they lifted up my mouth
and then for the first
week I couldn't feel my,
I can hardly feel my mouth
now to be honest with you.
(audience laughs)
But I couldn't find my mouth.
- That would be handy
in certain scenarios.
- Yeah but it's all numb
and it was up at one side
And I looked like Elvis.
And all the kids and Ozzy are going
"Why are you snarling at me?"
I'm like "I'm not snarling,
I'm not doing anything!"
But it was this, it was going up like.